and breaking news here just within the
last 30 minutes the nfl network and espn
reporting that raiders coach john gruden
has informed his staff he plans to
resign this afterward of more emails
with more insults have now surfaced
sports director chris matthews joining
us now with the latest on this breaking
news chris well thank you denise you
have huge breaking news this evening
according to as you mentioned espn and
the nfl network raiders coach john
gruden stepping down as coach of the
raiders all this stemming from contents
of leaked emails written in 2011 words
that included racist imagery
misogynistic and anti-gay language
derogatory comments directed at many
people in the nfl the commissioner other
players and even owners new york times
releasing a lengthy article detailing
some of the contents from those leaked
emails calling the commissioner roger
goodell an expletive also saying that
goodell should not have pressured jeff
fisher then coach of the rams to draft
quote queers a reference to michael sam
a gay player chosen by the team in 2014.
there are many more hurtful words in
those emails the first email the surface
was directed at nfl players the marie
smith he responded today saying among
other things the fight against racism
racist tropes and intolerance is not
over this is not about an email as much
as it is about pervasive beliefs by some
that people who look like me can be
treated as less once again just after
six o'clock john gruden announcing he is
resigning as head coach of the raiders
just four years ago signing that 10-year
100 million dollar contract we are
camped out at intermountain healthcare
performance center just in case the
raiders decide to talk to the media
tonight lots of unanswered questions who
will ride out the rest of the season as
head coach we should find out tonight
for sure by tomorrow